the key witness in Bill Cosby's sexual
assault trial stood by her story over
two days of cross-examination
Andrea constant was on the stand for
about four hours yesterday
Cosby's defense team tried to reveal
inconsistencies in her account based on
phone records the 79 year old actor
comedian looked down at the defense
table for most of the morning Cosby
denies the charges against him CBS News
legal analyst Ricky Clayman is here and
joins us to discuss the case Ricky good
to see you
nice to see you so she was on the stand
for two days about eight hours of
testimony what kind of witness was she
do you think she caused any damage she
really is a good witness for the
prosecution she's very very strong this
is a woman who comes across as together
sensible someone who is willing to say
what she doesn't remember and sticks to
her stories so for the prosecution they
have to be really pleased with her and
in fact if I were the prosecutor I would
have put her on first as I think she was
the stronger of the two women her mother
also testified Herman's mother her
mother follows up after the defense
cross-examination I want to get to the
defense side of that too but her mother
I do think is strong because what her
mother shows us is what happens when you
have to see your daughter start to fall
apart and not understand why then you
find out your daughter says she was
sexually assaulted and mother makes
phone calls to Bill Cosby and then has
the ability to say what he related to
her and in fact taped some of those
calls so what does the defense have to
do well the defense is in a bind here
the defense can do all they want to try
to cross-examine her as they did for
many many hours and say well look you
called in 53 times after this alleged
sexual assault you had been to his home
for intimate dinners before the sexual
assault you had laid on a bed next to
him in Foxwoods casino before the sexual
assault and you even brought him gifts
after the sexual assault so really
what's your story Miss Constance says
the defense is your story that you
really wanted this kind of an encounter
with him
why is it consensual and then did you
decide because perhaps you were
embarrassed that you wanted to make a
little money by suing him how does she
answer those questions
she was solid she is unafraid of saying
look he was at Temple University he was
a powerful trustee I had to answer his
phone calls he she was a good I called
him back she was a coach
she was a coach and that she was someone
who says there is nothing I did that
would have made me that I would have
done in any other way I needed to talk
to him about this but I didn't know how
we also have to remember Nora this is
2004 this is not 2017 attitudes about
sexual assault and how women react and
interact and how jurors perceive them
may be quite tip well the first witness
you said you said you would have called
Andrea the first witness was someone
named Kelly Johnson who also claims that
she had had an encounter with Bill Cosby
I think that Carolyn Kelly Johnson first
was a mistake I don't think ultimately
make me may make any difference but
Kelly Johnson is someone who is not as
good a witness as Andrea constant and
beefing up Kelly Johnson's testimony by
Kelly Johnson's own mother and Kelly
Johnson's own lawyer is something I've
never seen before in a courtroom and
she's not the main witness so we may
have seriously same league with strength
yes Ricky Clayman thank you so much